hi hello guten tag bitte Schoen boy Pat
here welcome to yandere simulator a game
about love friendship and murdering
people so this game is far from done it
gets updated frequently I love her
outfit
I want it where can I get it if you find
it please send it to me so now today in
this today's episode we're gonna bully
people now I'm clear strictly against
bullying let's just let that be clear
but video games are video games man and
video game like video games do what they
want alright so here we go Monday
morning waking up in the morning gotta
be fresh gotta go downstairs let's say
let's grab a knife you never know when
you you don't need them one none yeah
also a very important thing that we
missed
there is erotic manga scattered all
around the schoolyard let's see if we
can find there's what got you now
[ __ ]
so I know who planted all these erotic
mango Christ a schoolyard
but I salute you sir first of all we
gotta increase repetition done second of
all we're gonna bully one of these
ladies and remember which one they have
bigger tests than I do I'm alone I think
that's a good reason to bully someone
that's not fair
why can't I have big alligators like
mako-chan and spiral hair chan what's
what's the problem see mine is just
getting smaller oh how I wish I have
Sugoi loli titties but I want really
huge mammaries that too much to ask
I don't think so I don't think so at all
let's take a picture of her while she's
not she she doesn't have a crush that's
good what about you do you have any
crushes hmm she has a crush on some pie
this will not be forgiven
what forgotten oh she got a phone call
interesting always juicy well it's just
one more time oh we got some intel on
her which means we can gossip all right
let's gossip about spiral Chan Coco Kona
Haruka you haven't been acting like your
usual self lately
is something bothering you this is what
you get for having giant titties okay so
now we're gonna put a locker I'm gonna
put a note in her locket which which
Locker is hurtak heroness okay we've
done this before don't worry about it so
now we're home we can talk [ __ ] on the
internet like everyone desk
today I saw kanako-chan ancient sir City
she was she was engaging in compensated
dating post
oh yeah my job here is done
now it's time to read some erotic manga
alright well we have so much selection
this one is a classic I love this one
really it just just that come on I
wanted to read it you kidding me
look at her see you alone ha it's just a
game guys bullying is bad never bully
anyone look at her rep it's so [ __ ] okay
I think I think we're gonna bring her to
the point of suicide
this is what you get for having a crush
on senpai [ __ ] look at her
oh Jesus look at her desk man everyone
hates her [ __ ] hell all the woman
with the penny shot girl only one with
the penny shots all I wonder what it is
a plenty shot girl all I wanted was to
pay the shots all I what I want to get a
penny shot girl now all about our
another penny shots I think maybe if if
we done it right she should have killed
ourselves now what yellow model Chi
yellow bottle sipping no one sees me I'm
a kitty cat of the Nate that's right
baby
how can she not see me how notice me
hey girl you're trash
I guess I'll just play some senpai of
the night amazing this is my new
favorite game of all time I ask myself
that every day
bah [ __ ] ass licking piece of
[ __ ] arretez take that [ __ ]
another dick face
are you kidding mad that's how it's done
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fake da [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] if I can't have some
pie but no one can one more head in
there [ __ ] ass going alright well that
was awesome wasn't it yeah yeah that was
great the academic Institute is a
boarding school that teaches magical
arts the [ __ ] was that is that all I
guess is scratched what what the [ __ ]